It's JL Krista from the bonfire and I'm here to answer the internet.
Would you rather watch your parents have sex every night or join in one time to
make it stop? Hmm,
I didn't think he was gonna be such pressing questions. I, uh,
I jump in one time. See the cyst fields.
There should be a parentheses here of like jumping one time,
but you only have to do some light play with like, Oh, you know what?
Both my parents remarried. So yeah,
if I could do my dad's step-mom I'll join in. Yeah. I found a loophole.
Everybody I'll reference you to the people versus
if your belly button was a real button and you could push it once a day to make
anything happen, what would it do?
Well as a fact that my belly button so deep,
I feel like it'd be like the reset button on the back of a TV or something.
We have to start a clock radio, like a pencil out.
Yeah. Yeah. You have to get a pin in there. And then I just reset.
Would you lose all your own memories or never be able to make new ones
lose all the old ones? That's a breeze fact. He'd grown up in the nineties.
No brainer.
You'd rather wake up every morning to a or a hundred dollars under your pillow.
Again, a lot of Prince C's here. Who's the from, uh,
I feel like this is one of those leper contracts where I answer a blow job.
And then it's like every morning I took my grandmother knocking on the door or
something. I didn't say from who [inaudible]. So I guess the a hundred bucks,
would you rather know when you're going to die or how you're going to die?
When, because, uh, that week leading up to a lot of crime,
a lot of crime. Well, my crime in the purge B Oh man.
Hmm.
It will be to make all the girls who rejected me in high school have to watch my
half-hour special. So you could have had that's the,
that's the millennial version of tired of getting sand kicked in your face.
Would you rather be blind or dickless blind?
You think that one through? Yeah.
That's why there's that easy decision to make blind.
Let me think about it for a second. I'm going to think about something else.
Would you rather have a girl who talks too much during sex? Well,
the room has spoke, but wait, there's another answer or,
or I know, I know without a commotion, this is a tough one,
but there's a second part or is completely silent.
Um, Hm. Again, a lot of parentheses.
What's she saying when she's talking too much, do you know what I mean?
Is she like, man, your Dick is small. Oh, it was positive.
Whenever I'd rather have a girl who speaks positively during sex or completely
silent, uh, positive. I need a lot of encouragement.
As long as you ask me to take my tank top off,
Would you rather, every time you come,
it comes out of your mouth or it's a two liter bottles worth. Again,
this is a no brainer, two little bottles worth.
What do you mean inconvenient to what? I mean to my target.
Sure. But that girl knew what she was getting in.
So you think I haven't talked about this publicly already. I go,
I'm going to come. And she goes, where do you want to come?
I'm going to go back up.
Would you rather have half your teeth or half your hair?
I'm going to need a week with this one. I have a fear of, Oh,
I don't have a hair problem. So I can't even wrap my brain around.
Would that be like, Oh, half my teeth,
because I'd rather get fake teeth in a hairpiece.
You can't be fat and a hairpiece unless you have a Miata and you're going to get
so much hearse and 91.
1991.
Guys. It was a fantastic year.
You never know.
Is going to get him. You know what I mean? These are the notes.
These are the notes we got to take.
If there was a Royal rumble with food mascots who would win
Mr. Peanut, I just picture, he's got a lot of tricks up his sleeve guide,
a Monaco. He's definitely got some sort of a powdery blows at you.
Something like that. He spreads himself and your butt crack.
And then dogs start licking you.
Dogs.
Would you rather walk in, uh,
would you rather walk in on your dad having sex with a dog again,
or a dog having sex with your dad,
a dad having sex with a dog.
I'm going to answer it as much more scientifically than we all thought. Uh,
I feel like my dad given the biz, he was looking for a hole.
You know what I mean? Just an inviting, warm, wet hole, letting the dog my dad.
That means my dad's either like a total freak. Just gone.
Beastiality not for he owes, he owes our dog money.
Awesome.